you guys are both from Iowa yes sir have
you ever been called a dreamer you know
coming from a small town um I I don't
think specifically no no I don't think
specifically about that word no no no
there was another word yeah dream yeah I
did exactly sleeping you're gonna yeah
yeah exactly so what do you think is
aside from the obvious talent that you
both possess what do you think okay we
can we can talk about that but but what
do you think has been the secret to
being consistent with your work
booking roles consistently because this
is not an easy thing to do and you both
seem to have mastered I you know you're
just knowing that I really love this job
and and knowing that I'm grateful for it
it's something that I want to do for a
very long time so I'm mindful of it and
I think that I kind of try to be
thoughtful about it and and I mean I
think that's it and and also just having
a level of perseverance and always
keeping your chin up you know I think
with any job or any career you know
you're always going to have an ebb and
flow and it's gonna be tough some days
and it's gonna be great others and I
just think that if you really love what
you do then you just keep moving forward
so you know just staying encouraged yeah
show up that's the hardest thing I mean
there's a lot of people that never get
to that first audition scam because it's
hard to get to that first yeah mm-hmm
you show up you do your best and you
just always try to keep getting better
and the rest of its kind of out of your
hands you know in terms of looking at a
script you're both presented with a
script whether it's Fort Bliss or
another one do you have a number of sort
of checklist items that you go through
to determine it's it's the writing first
and foremost for me it can be any genre
you know we're actors we both like to do
things all over the place you know
creatively but it has to be the writing
has to be
good and and for me it doesn't matter if
you're a first-time writer director and
actors you know actors there are a lot
of great actors there that we know
people's names and there's a lot of
actors out there that we don't know so
I'm open creatively it just comes down
to the writing in the material there's a
thing that happens where you look at the
page number you're on the first page
number you're on and if you're on page
eight you're already looking at the page
number that's a bad sign yeah if you
look down and you're on page 67 or
something and you're open you're still
awake yeah and you're good the scripts a
good read yeah yeah right you know that
saying that oh I'm not competitive with
other actors I'm just competitive with
myself I don't know if that applies to
either of you but let's say that you are
just competitive with yourselves what
does that entail in terms of being an
actor like what how are you competitive
with yourself for each role for booking
for staying fresh I mean honest compare
from my point of view for myself I I do
I have a pretty high standard for myself
it's in terms of when I take on a role
I'm going to do whatever research I
possibly can you know in terms of Fort
Bliss it was really important to me I
mean these are these are real people
that we're portraying and if you're not
going to do it the right way then I'm if
I'm not going to do it you know and I
don't think anybody else should do it
unless they're gonna do whatever whether
they're playing um a truck driver a
doctor you know soldier whatever it is
so that's that's a very high standard
for myself and in doing that and having
that approach gives me confidence so
that's um first and foremost it's just
it's just doing the research and doing
the work every every job is a new
opportunity
you know you have to be willing I mean
you can't get so into like well I've got
to keep up you got to be willing to take
a shot on something and fall on your
face too but every single thing is a new
experience it's a chance to learn about
something else a chance to work with
some new great people so I don't know
the older I get the I don't the less
competitive I feel about it
you know it's just I feel like I'm lucky
to be here and it's it's more of a
collaborative thing you know great thank
you guys I appreciate it